this is wild
hanukkah's chimps are our closest
relatives in the animal kingdom there is
less than 2% difference in our DNA
unfortunately our genetic similarities
mean that certain illnesses can also
pass easily between us and our forest
cousins and that can spell trouble for
chimpanzees
muhuali is a tourist destination in
Tanzania the park is home to an
estimated 700 chimps normally when
people come crashing through the trees
chimps scatter but here in Mohali a
group of about 60 individuals has been
habituated to humans they're comfortable
around people here's the dilemma tourism
is important from a Holly Mountain
National Park brings in revenue and it
brings worldwide attention to the
chimpanzees but in addition to the
dollars the tourists may also be
bringing diseases there has been growing
concern among the researchers in Mohali
over a respiratory infection that seems
to be spreading among the chimps is that
nasal discharge something out of here so
they get they get depressed and they
don't want to do much better when they
eat a whole lot he's probably got a
fever and then today we'll probably see
that they won't move very far in the
early 90s a flu-like illness killed off
at least 11 of majalis chimps
researchers suspected the animals caught
it from humans but they weren't able to
prove it another outbreak like that
could devastate majalis chimp population
and it's ecotourism program so the
researchers are taking this very
seriously although he's a relatively
young chimp this male whom the
researchers call Cesar is old enough
that he should be able to survive the
illness the main concern is for two
infants who just recently started
coughing
Swinson and I go off to find a female
nicknamed Cynthia and her two-month-old
baby the trackers give us bad news the
baby was still alive yesterday this
morning it's it's not it's it's gone
she's carrying the the carcass around
now which will continue to do or quite a
long time usually maybe a week or two
even the researchers speculate that the
cause of death was an infectious disease
contracted from humans but they won't
know for sure until Swinson scat samples
are analyzed he's already sent back more
than a hundred to the lab where they
will be screened for viruses bacteria
stress-related hormones and more
hopefully they'll reveal where the
illness came from and how its spread
among the chimps that information could
help determine whether Taurus should be
kept further away from the chimps and
how long they should be allowed to
observe them on each visitor
check for wild condoms on your local PBS
station
sponsored by National Geographic mission
programs taking science and exploration
into the new millennium